there is a benefit to being busy
that makes it harder to find time to cry
even when around you
reasons are piling up
for the men and women of Ukraine's rail
system it has been a year of focusing on
the work
whether they've been rebuilding tracks
riding the tracks
or getting people to the right tracks
[Music]
the director of kiev's Central Station
busy helps people cope he says and then
he tells the story of a train driver
whose wife was killed by Russian troops
I mean
now a train's job is to move forward
well the workers who keep Ukraine's
trains rolling seem to have the same
degree of dedication to the same
direction
driving his train through Land retaken
by Ukraine's military Roman chapoval
knows Russian forces aren't far
he just doesn't have time for fear
foreign
there have been trips conductor Lilia
seminova didn't think she'd make it
through there was one where she called
her family to say goodbye and another
where she thought she'd die before she
could even make that call
Clark is
after a year keeping Ukraine's trains
running through a war the men and women
of the country's rail service have
earned new names they've been called the
iron people and Ukraine's second Army a
force of 230
000 people
well this is their General Alexander
commission took over as head of the rail
service just seven months before The
Invasion he was a finance guy he was
supposed to work on modernizing the
company
instead he's been attending funerals he
won't say how many
we lost more than 300 Railway men and
more than 700 are injured but meanwhile
we keep standing and we will withstand
the rail service was important before
The Invasion but crucial sense with
roads and bridges bombed and air travel
impossible much of the country is cut
off to everything but Rail lines they
have become lifelines
in the early days of the invasion the
focus was on evacuations trains went
wherever they could reach carrying
humanitarian Aid into conflict zones and
people out
3.8 million refugees were moved mostly
to safer areas in the West
Lilia says some trains were so packed
there was no space to move
was chaotic and tragic she says
people were leaving their homes not
knowing where they were going only that
they couldn't stay
that period is a blur shifts lasted days
the staff even went without food Lilia
remembers a trip out of the East where
there was fighting ahead of them
know how they'd make it through
um
this was one of the worst days for the
rail Service April 8th a Russian Missile
hit the railway station in crematorisk
60 people were killed including seven
children Lilia had just gotten out on a
train carrying about 5 000 people she
says they were full
and it left thousands behind us
now in the beginning Russian forces for
the most part left rail infrastructure
alone the thinking was once Russia took
over it would use the tracks for its own
supply lines the pushback changed that
Playbook
Ukrainian military says Russian forces
Target Rail lines this was a still
unconfirmed attack by Marine Drone this
month on a bridge outside Odessa the
goal would have been to cut off weapon
shipments from NATO countries by
Ukrainian Railways Alexander won't
discuss how the rail service works with
the military but that they're close
isn't a secret
it's something I never commented since
the beginning of the war
but it doesn't mean like you know
everything
keeping Ukrainian industry going and
keeping the country going means moving
raw materials in and finished products
out it's also meant redirecting millions
of tons of grain and corn through new
routes to European ports in many cases
train stations have now become Emergency
Shelters for ukrainians who have no
water electricity or homes after an
attack and there's also a new term Iron
diplomacy every world leader and every
celebrity who's visited Kiev went in and
out by Ukrainian train I really want to
take a moment to say thank you to all
the railway workers of Ukraine
for 12 months the Russian attacks have
been keeping repair Crews busy
and those Crews have gotten quicker jobs
that used to take a week now take a day
time out in the open means time
potentially exposed to showing they
don't Flinch at bombs off in the
distance anymore although they do worry
about booby trapses
Alexander has been with Cruz on jobs
when workers were killed he doesn't
spend a lot of time in the office he's
in and out of hot spots by train he says
to send a message he'd never ask anyone
to go somewhere he wouldn't go himself
Alexander also made Senior managers pick
who would replace them if they're killed
he says no person is more important than
keeping the trains running their real
system saved millions of people that's
why it's definitely more important than
me
that is a sentiment shared seemingly
across the board every rail worker we
spoke to said Duty outweighs
dangerous foreign
you know
when I meet Railway Man I always shake
their hand and say something like thank
you for what you do you are doing her
right work and you know what they say
they usually say come on we're just
doing what we have to do we're just
doing our job now Alexander admits there
are moments where the pressure is
overwhelming it's been a tough year
spent without his family for their
safety they were sent out of the country
that's the highest price I am personally
paying for this war not seeing my boys
I've got two boys I've got two sons
I really miss them
[Music]
as Ukrainian troops retake territories
from Russian forces the motto is first
the tanks go in then the trains it's
Ukraine's rail workers that reconnect
the land and the people with the rest of
the country
generators are moved into the station
then food Heat and the internet
the trains that roll down these tracks
to liberated towns and cities
[Music]
carry comfort and Communications and in
many ways confidence
is
foreign